[Musique]
elle se prénomme luna et pèse 2 kg 520 g
né à 3 heures du matin à fort de france
avec un petit mois d'av ans la petite
fille est le deuxième bébé de l'année
2020 en martinique les prières de ses
parents mariane stanley semblent avoir
été exaucé
il sera compté énormément pour nous
parce qu'on souhaitait qu'elle fasse
partie des premiers bébés de l'année
et puis voilà on a réussi notre pari
pour ce que ça peut lui porter chance à
j'espère j'espère c'est une enfant béni
parce que c'est par la prière et puis en
lui parlant qu'on a eu c'est un faire
qu'est la leaf le pony si marianne et
mère pour la troisième fois à trinité
adeline a donné ce matin des sensations
tout premier enfant
7 sth 3 kg 5 et le premier garçon de
2020 il est né à 8h34 après de longues
heures passées en salle d'accouchement
très éprouvé sa maman a encore bien du
mal à réaliser c'est que du bonheur on
s'attendait pas à cette date
et finalement c'est à vous aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on m'avait dit de 29 décembre
et finalement nous sommes le premier
qu'est ce que vous ressentez toutes
nouvelles mamans ses quatre premiers
enfants et les faire
réalisée entre les premières
contractions et la mise au monde de
l'enfant près de six heures se sont
écoulées
l'équipe médicale salue le courage de la
jeune maman avait défilé d'accrocher
sans péridurale donc on a essayé de
l'accompagner en tout cas au mieux pour
gérer sa douleur faut effectivement
établi une relation de confiance
qu'elles puissent nous faire confiance
d'abord et puis des exercices de
respiration et puis son mari aussi on a
pu vraiment s'appuyer sur lui parce que
il l'a vraiment bien aidé je suis encore
un peu sous le sous le choc parce qu'en
fait elle a beaucoup souffert et voilà
elle n'aurait peut-être pas pu supporter
la souffrance seul sait je pense que ça
aurait été difficile pour elle et pour
qu'elle puisse en faire et qu'elle a la
possibilité de s'appuyer sur moi c'est
important
après l' attente interminable les
efforts et la souffrance ces jeunes
parents du 1er janvier vont maintenant
enfin pouvoir goûter à un bonheur bien
mérité
je
ce jeu
[Musique]